joining us at our c-span table John
stopper he's the co-author of this book
banana Republicans how the right-wing is
turning America into a one-party state
thanks for joining us this morning
my pleasure Pedro you have a recent
op-ed about Ralph Nader and Republicans
tell us a little bit about that well
that up add very much comes from our
book banana Republicans that Sheldon
Rampton I've written because in the book
we look at right-wing think tanks we
look at corporate front groups like
citizens for a sound economy which is a
I think about fifteen million dollar a
year organization now gets most of its
money from big corporations like Exxon
Mobil and Microsoft and Ayn Rand and ADM
and is out there campaigning to help put
Ralph Nader on the ballot in the
November election and of course this is
ironic campaigning for Ralph Nader isn't
he the sworn enemy of corporate power
yes he is but obviously the Republicans
like Dick Armey who's the chairman of
citizens for a sound economy think that
campaigning for Nader is going to take
votes away from Carey and so across the
country in battleground states like mine
Wisconsin states like Oregon Michigan
Florida we see dick Armey's group
campaigning for Ralph Nader so Sheldon
and I penned a piece on that and pointed
out that this is a bit of an ironic
situation where the great crusader
against corporations seems to be the not
so secret corporate weapon to keep
George Bush in the White House does it
speak to a larger issue about what
Republicans are thinking about this
fall's election well I think it
indicates that Republicans and Democrats
both feel that the Nader vote could very
much help primarily George Bush and
while the Republicans seem to be pulling
out all the stops
to support Nader for instance just the
other day some 43,000 signatures for
Nader according to an Associated Press
report out right now were turned in to
help as Candice in Michigan apparently
turned in by the Republican Party and
the Democrats are doing everything they
can in an organized way instead sly
Corrigan in Arizona to keep them laughed
about so clearly this is a very
polarized country but there's unity
among the Democrats and Republicans and
that they each seem to believe that a
vote for Nader is more likely to help
George Bush on a larger issue a lot has
been made about making sure that Dick
Cheney is out in front and center saying
that he will be the vice presidential
candidate come again for this uh this
fall or a vice president he'll remain in
his position I should say yeah and and
who knows I think one thing that's going
on right now and my organization is
nonpartisan non-political but I think
one thing that's going on right now is
part of the Republican strategy is
they're happy to see all this flak out
there they are happy to see Ralph Nader
and the Democrats mix it up over ballot
access they don't even mind that
Republicans are campaigning for Nader
and the more we talk about whether dick
is going to stay or dick is going to go
well that's let's talk about how did we
get into Iraq and what the heck's going
on there
Banana Republic ins is the book that our
guest has co-authored who is Sheldon
Rampton Sheldon Rampton had both right
for center for media and democracy we've
worked for that nonprofit out of Madison
Wisconsin for 10 years this is our fifth
book previous book was weapons of mass
deception the uses of propaganda and
Bush's war in Iraq which came out last
summer and the center exists for what
well the center exists and has existed
since I've founded a ten years ago
specifically to investigate hidden PR
and propaganda and spin campaigns
perception management campaigns as
they're organized and waged by
government agencies and corporations so
we have a feature on our website at PR
Watch org we have a feature called
disinfo pedia where you can go and you
can find out all sorts of information
about groups like your previous Gas
Center for Consumer Freedom you can look
at their food industry funding or
citizens for a sound economy you can
look at their ExxonMobil funding our
funding comes primarily from three
sources
the books the children and I write are
completely the property of the center
the books bring in some money
individuals fund us and also foundations
and on our website you can look up and
see which foundations fund us we have a
policy against accepting grants from
corporations or government our guests
will be with us your phone what calls
welcomed on the lines that you will see
on your screen two oh two five eight
five three eight eight zero eight eighty
one for those who support Democrats 202
five eight five three eight eight zero
for those who support President Bush and
it's two O two five eight five three
eighty two if you support other
candidates first call for our guest
Orange County go ahead hello hi go ahead
good morning it I hear some more it is C
coming out here thank you I have a my
father died last year at ninety six
years old he was quite a wise man he
always told us you could go to school
and get all the book learn and you can
get but if you don't have common sense
you haven't got much and that's what I
see with these Democrats are like a
bunch of little kids that don't get
their way and don't look at the facts
they better start looking at the
invasion of the Mexicans coming into
this country you think we've got
terrorists you better watch what
Mexicans coming into this country they
are taking over all the government
offices out here and nobody's paying
attention that a carry just came out and
said he's going to give him oh as the
first hundred days he's just going to
let him come right in well to come right
in they have done and the gang violence
and everything we've got terrorists
right here in our streets of Los Angeles
John Stauber I don't have any response
to that sort of racist stuff I'm not
even going to go there but Quincy
Massachusetts
good morning gentlemen and thank you
very much for c-span Pedro I would like
to compliment Brian because I think he's
the best interviewer on TV my question
for the gentlemen is this we are in a
position now where and I'm also very
glad that you answered the question as
to where your funding comes from because
I think anybody with a modicum of
intelligence realizes that if you
all the money there's an agenda
somewhere and what I am going to ask you
sir is do you think the current
administration are mercenary ideologues
that are serving their corporate clients
or are they delusional or a little bit
of both
thank you I wait for your reply okay
that's the question I'll answer I can't
speak for this administration as far as
what their motivations are I think
that's on the mind of a lot of Americans
right now in our previous book Sheldon
and I took a look at the way the war in
Iraq was sold to this country and one
thing we argue in weapons of mass
deception is that the war in Iraq could
have never been sold had the mainstream
US media really contested these dubious
and false claims upon which the war was
based and I think that in my lifetime
and I'm 51 this upcoming election is
probably not only the most important but
it's going to be the most contentious
and polarized I've ever seen in our book
banana Republicans what we look at is
how the right wing has managed to turn
America into what we call a one-party
state and while Democrats and liberals
would like to think that there's a real
boxing match going on politically and
after all Al Gore won the popular vote
in the last election with half a million
votes I was very close the reality is
that for the first time since 1932 the
Republican Party now controls the
Supreme Court the presidency both
branches of Congress I would argue that
they also control the most important
opinion shaping media right now in the
United States Bisset despite all this
talk about the liberal media the fact is
that right-wing talk radio and Fox News
in my opinion are the most important
opinion shaping media in the US and for
the first time since 1952 most governors
are
and most state legislatures are
controlled by Republicans so what we
look at in our book is how the
conservative movement over the last 40
years with discipline with planning with
funding
we're supportive right-wing foundations
and people like the Koch brothers and
Scafe and Bradley and Mellon have built
this apparatus that now dominates our
government and it's clearly a far-right
ideology behind the Republicans but for
the sake of PR they'd like to spin it
more as compassionate conservatism
Summersville West Virginia yes um I'm
just like state my opinion
me and my wife both were for President
Bush supporting 100% because he stands
up for what he believes in and you know
even the unpopular stance he's you know
Stenson's up for it and in my opinion
the terrorists they want support Kerry
they don't want President Bush in there
cuz President Bush's after him I'm a
veteran I'm very proud of the president
United States and I hope that he gets
reelected you know we're behind him 100%
and you know that's all I have to say
stubborn I just want to respond to one
of your remarks and maybe I should
preface my response by saying I'm not
here to advocate for any presidential
candidate organization is nonpartisan
non-political but when you say that the
terrorists support Kerry you know I
think you're saying something that the
Republicans love to hear and we actually
satirize this with the time tomorrow
cartoon on the cover of banana
Republicans somebody obviously
characterized Republicans saying to a
caricature eyes liberal you're either
with the Republican Party or you're with
the terrorists frankly I think much
stronger argument could be made that if
Osama bin Laden is alive somewhere in a
cave in Pakistan he must be very happy
with the decision of this administration
to launch an attack
Iraq that's got us bogged down in what
amounts to a very bloody very expensive
very unpopular recruiting campaign
that's very successful for al-qaeda
headers bill Illinois yes how you doin
today fine thanks
well I've got just a little uh dilemma
going on I've got a situation that I
proposed a plan for the President to
hire over four billion people throughout
the United States of two weeks having
each governor taking a go to folks small
companies and hire people on a four hour
basis instead of an eight-hour shift
work you just seem to think we have a
problem with jobs in the United States
not enough of them I'm just trying to
figure out what the point that that
that's the issue but we ought to also
need to take and take a percentage of
like ten percent of a check towards
retirement two percent towards medical
we also need to take a and have our high
schools trade classes go and repair our
lower middle grade schools we also need
to take this device that I built that
has five to ten different uses in human
nature and just had the president take
one patent give to 50 governors and say
go build it well sir I think good luck
in promoting those ideas you talked
about corporate influences should in
Americans be concerned about the
influence that some have said about the
trial lawyer industry and the backing of
Senator Edwards well that's certainly
the Republican pitch you know the right
and the Republican Party have been
trying to conduct what they sort of
euphemistically called tort reform for
quite a while I think senator Edwards is
very interesting because he's apparently
gotten to where he's got as a
hard-charging trial attorney without
running from this issue so I think one
thing the
Nader is done repeatedly and Ralph has
done many great and good things is he's
really pointed out to the American
people how in most cases in many places
it's only a trial attorney who stands
between the public and corporate greed
so I think we're going to get actually
an interesting debate on this whole
issue of quote-unquote tort reform the
power of trial attorneys versus the
power of corporate America yeah the
trial attorneys are a big powerful lobby
but they're only one lobby you put that
up against the industry that's
supporting Bush right now you know it's
very interesting people say well both
parties are dominated by big
corporations they get money from big
corporations big corporations play both
sides of the street they give money to
Democrats and Republicans but since the
Republicans took over both houses of
Congress in 2002 overwhelmingly now in
every economic sector and we document
this in banana Republicans the business
money is flowing to Republican
candidates the Republican Party has eyes
been primarily the part of the big
business and now that the Republicans
dominated all branches of the federal
government has been a major shift in the
last two years into where Republican
money is going the only sectors of the
economy that give most of their money to
Democrats are essentially media and
high-technology and trial attorneys you
brought up mr. Nader will he be a
liability for mr. Kerry do you think
well that's what mr. Kerry thinks and
it's obviously what the Republicans
think Nader is going to apparently a run
and run hard all the way to November you
know I was reading a San Francisco
Chronicle article that's out today and
Ralph Nader had his campaign kickoff in
San Francisco yesterday is very
interesting because this was his big
campaign kickoff in San Francisco City
that came close to electing a green
candidate mayor recently and the kickoff
only drew 500 people four years ago
there would have been five or ten or
even 15,000 people out for an event like
that
I think Nader's having a very
called time generating supported the
grassroots this time around which may be
why he's just looking with a wink and a
nod Republicans support to get him on
the belt but I have no doubt that
nothing will dissuade well from running
through November and both the
Republicans and the Democrats think he's
more likely to help Republicans John
Stauber is the executive director and
founder of the Center for Media and
democracy he lives in work it works in
Madison Wisconsin San Diego California
San Diego I'm sorry yes hello
I'd like to say to this gentleman what
kind of ignorant public do you think
you're talking to when you say you're
nonpartisan and non-political I'd like
to answer that question
because you're far from he is kind of
like your flip flopping flopping just
like Senator Kerry anyway you must you
must think that we don't understand this
type that type of rhetoric
well anyway also to are you uh are you
one of these parasites that they seem to
come out of every crevice know anything
I would like to have an intelligent
conversation with you because I can tell
you're an intelligent woman but when you
call me a parasite who comes out of a
crevice again I'm not even going to
bother to respond to that sort of
garbage I'm sorry goodbye what about the
first part of her question though well
okay I'll respond to that to You Pedro
nonpartisan non-political my
organization Center for Media and
democracy is a non-profit tax-exempt
organization we don't advocate for any
candidate it's a nonpartisan
non-political organization Yellow
Springs Ohio good morning John
good morning um first I like to say I
thank you no matter what party you're
from for bringing the truth out I am a
American citizen that job has been sold
twice a lot of our workers I mean plant
our sister plants have been on packing
up and send in our jobs to different
countries I just lost my brother because
he didn't have adequate health care
I have young student there was a tax
break but now all the schools are now
falling where the states are raising
taxes on me you know trying to make up
for the money that is lost I have an
elderly mother I'm taken care of
who medication runs over $800 a month
and look and from that that um health
care that the current administration is
bragging on it's just $600 a year my
concern with America with this war I
have family members that over there
fighting and cannot speak out of the
injustice that this current
administration is um um preventing like
this weapons of mass destruction without
Bush walking around hollering on the
bombs and they call will have to leave
it right there let our guest answer well
let me pick up on what you said about
weapons of mass destruction or is
Sheldon Rampton and I titled it in our
previous book weapons of mass deception
one thing we reported on in that book is
how the Republicans brilliantly used the
march to war in Iraq in the summer and
fall of 2002 to keep the focus on the
war on terror so that the economic and
social issues that you're talking about
and that you're suffering under weren't
part of the debate and discussion and I
think this is going to be a very
interesting election November for a lot
of reasons but I'm hoping that we're
going to see a debate and discussion on
a wide range of issues including the
ones you brought up the networks put out
their plan for coverage of the elections
one hour at night your thoughts a little
different than the c-span coverage I
guess didn't want to say that well you
know the elections have become these
horrific canned affairs sort of like the
debates you know it would be very
interesting if the Republicans insisted
on putting Ralph Nader in the debates
they'll work to get them on the ballot
but I think they're too afraid of
him to put him in the debates because
what if he turns on the president he
could have a heck of an impact these
conventions and the debates are staged
Affairs you know you've got both the
Democratic and Republican Party
candidate having to go sequester
themselves for a week to prepare for kin
debates that are only between the
Democrat and Republican party so I think
the networks are turning after the
conventions because there's not a lot
going on there from their standpoint I
think the public turns off to the
conventions and the debates and I think
when Ralph Nader says both parties are
boring and canned and dominated by major
corporate interest who's got a good
point do you think that as far as the
coverage of conventions is reported
they'll be a place for the protesters
that will occur at each well I think
especially the Republican Party
convention in New York we're going to
see hundreds of thousands of protesters
I'm old enough to remember 68 in Chicago
there were thousands of protesters I
wasn't there I was in high school in
Wisconsin but the protests are going to
be a significant part of the Republican
convention certainly and I'm sure the
right will try to spin that to help
President Bush I mean they're already
making noises like protesting the
convention is related to terrorism we
heard one of the caller's say well the
president is fighting the war on terror
against the terrorist vote for the
president and you may have heard the
story about ClearChannel holding a
billboard in Times Square now yeah it's
disgusting
I mean Clear Channel huge the biggest
radio conglomerate in the country
organized pro-war rallies
kick the Dixie Chicks off stations
because Natalie Maines exercised her
First Amendment American rights to say
one critical remark about the president
and now they're not allowing a peace
billboard to go up on their billboards
base in Times Square I mean is this
America or what actually I think they're
working with the hotel and all parties
about to try to resolve it I'm sure they
are Eugene Oregon yeah I first I just
wanted to point out that it's Oregon
Oregon when I first moved here from New
York give you say where has Oregon
but it organ just down that's my
Wisconsin accent sir do you um but I
really wanted you to explain how the how
right-wing talk radio and Fox equals the
you know classic definition of the
liberal left-wing media or at the New
York Times and the three depths but I
think over the last ten years it may
have become a almost an equal
counterweight but I can't see how you
can say that that radio and Fox is the
most influential part of the media today
it just it doesn't really add up I used
to be in the radio business I know what
radio can and cannot do and what the
numbers are um I mean it's kinda I was
like usually well first of all there's
an excellent book on this by Eric
Alterman who writes for the Nation
what liberal media it's an incredible
book well documented I would recommend
you to buy it or go to the library and
check it out for free but I think if you
look at the rise of the right-wing media
which we do in a chapter of banana
Republicans called the echo chamber what
you see is that this is a biased
partisan media with passion that's part
of the right movement the right wing
movement you know when Grover Norquist
holds his wednesday meeting every week
here in Washington and Americans for Tax
Reform the right-wing media right in
there with him getting on message and
it's a much more politically powerful
propaganda machine than anything you see
on the left when people talk about left
liberal media they start naming people
like Peter Jennings Phil Donahue well
Phil Donahue was liberal he used to be
on MSNBC but in March of 2003 they fired
him and an MSNBC memo said it was
because they didn't want somebody on
their network who was having people
critical at the march to war and
critical of the president so he was
booted off so much for your liberal
media you know
Fox after 9/11 became the dominant force
in cable TV and it's a totally different
type of coverage and if you look at
people like Ann Coulter who's all over
Fox these are people who really get a
lot of face time in their advocates in a
way that they just aren't liberal left
advocates like that we want to squeeze
another call but if you can get a quick
response to this email as as doesn't
does this political activity cut both
ways I recall my Democratic Party helped
Ross Perot's third party effort which
led to the election of President Clinton
we also got Perot in the debates of 92
and kept Nader off the debates in 2000
good points I don't see anything there
to disagree with I think the person is
correct in that analysis I you know
think that the Democrats are probably
making a mistake by trying to keep Nader
off the ballot because the Republicans
have made it clear that if Nader doesn't
have the grassroots power to get on
ballots in various states they're going
to help provide it and mater's made it
clear he's running through November what
he's saying is I want Kerry to address
these issues of corporate power and he's
not going to go away I don't think he's
going to support Kerry's made that clear
and at the same time I can't see the
Republicans demanding that Nader be put
in the debates because that is such a
wild card and Ralph Nader doesn't have
to spend a week behind closed door
prepping for debates he could walk in
the studio today and really mix it up it
would be quite interesting
Tork New York you are last call yeah hi
how are you fine thanks listen you know
previously it was the Communist Party
that had the front groups in the
fellow-travellers but beginning with Lee
Atwater and continuing to mr. Karl Rove
the Republican Party I think has been a
genius in organizing many many
Republican front groups under day in the
grover norquist the Club for Growth well
the gentleman though let me just respond
to that it you're absolutely right and
there even some former Marxist Leninist
types like David Horowitz the editor of
ramparts magazine back in the 60s who
loves to quote Lenin who is one of the
real guiding light and strategist for
the Republicans now who says like Lenin
said that politics is war and in war you
don't debate you were to annihilate your
enemy and I think these corporate front
groups that I'd mentioned like Center
for Consumer Freedom or citizens for a
sound economy are very much in that mold
this is the cover of the book by Sheldon
Rampton and John stopper banana
Republicans and we've had one more email
asked about Tom tomorrow who